[Aplausos]
después de meses de luchar por
posicionarse de buscar el apoyo de
funcionarios locales y de hacer
apariciones en los medios de
comunicación los 12 candidatos franceses
a las elecciones presidenciales de 2022
entraron en la recta final
este lunes comienza oficialmente la
campaña a menos de dos semanas de la
primera vuelta los carteles electorales
aparecen por primera vez en todo el país
ahora los residentes pueden venir a
echar un vistazo a su candidato y elegir
uno con sabiduría debería decir a partir
de ahora los medios de comunicación
franceses están obligados a dar a cada
candidato el mismo tiempo de cobertura
independientemente de sus posibilidades
de éxito los vídeos de campaña también
aparecen por primera vez en la
televisión pública de acuerdo con las
estrictas leyes electorales del país
antes de esta apertura varios candidatos
celebraron actos de campaña para
intentar animar a sus seguidores de cara
a la recta final la eterna candidata de
extrema derecha marine lepén estuvo en
guadalupe donde fue recibida con
protestas y abucheos por parte de
manifestantes anti racistas
y su rival el ik se celebró un gran
mitin en parís el candidato de la
izquierda jean luc mélenchon estuvo en
marsella donde dijo que votar por él
sería la mejor manera de alejar la
extrema derecha los votantes franceses
acudirán a las urnas el domingo 10 de
abril sin ningún candidato tiene una
mayoría absoluta los dos más votados
pasarán a una segunda vuelta dos semanas
después el 24 de abril